[Music]
jack do you want to be starting posture
with me
dude i'm third imposter whether i like
it or not it's not really a choice i
make
you've been the third imposter more than
imposter
we need to be impostor today together i
want it to happen i feel like that's
what needs to happen so all the salt can
just go away
dude i'm too nervous please do not oh
wait sorry
all right everything is good now there
shouldn't be any lag or anything do you
think lily could be like
oh no i'm alone here okay all right
there's other people here we got michael
you got lily oh no
what happened there is this kind of
sauce
that's no one died no best friend is
dead
oh how could you have done that to
cycuno oh you called me best friend
thanks jack you're dead you're dead
[Music]
why do you say that with a smile on your
face
michael yeah i can see the [ __ ] eating
grin from here
okay michael did you self-report
lily i'm looking at the tutorial on how
doors work right now i'm not
sure i mean i got
i i think skip well maybe it wasn't him
he said he was trying
to he's just really happy about dead
corpses i i get that
oh my god come on guys
michael don't kill me please i'm sorry
michael i skipped don't kill me
all right let's say the play from
michael that little minion
everyone's favorite moment of video
not vpn sponsor yeah yes i waited for
the north vpn
i know don't worry it's here nor vpn
sponsor
thank you oh let's just get uh let's
just get it out of the way
no savor it all right basically guys
you're browsing the internet without a
vpn
i was recently camping there was a bunch
of public wi-fi
what did i do i slapped on nordvpn and i
could browse
safely but also unrestricted a vpn
helps you become epic that's how it
works right now
there's a 68 discount really they pick
no other number all right you get one
additional month for free you heard this
i'm saying it again and you love it so
make sure you use the code pewdiepie i
highly recommend using nordvpn i use it
myself
and every time i get to use that it's
like
i'm so glad i had it it's one of those
services oh something's blocked on the
internet
bam nordvpn you're done oh i'm browsing
public wi-fi this isn't safe
bam nordvpn i'm done it's there it also
works on your mobile
but here's even more there they also
have nord pass
which is a app that lets you store
passwords and also come up with more
better epic passwords i know floor gang
2020 is an epic password
but everyone's gonna guess it all right
you need safer passwords
brute force my dude have you heard of it
they're gonna hack you in two seconds
they're gonna hack you faster than you
can say enter code pewdiepie nordvpn get
off a two-year plan that's how fast
they're going to hack you unless you
have a good password
so make sure you have saved passwords
and use nord
pass you need these services trust me
okay thank you sponsored
vpn.com oh but felix
i don't know about vpn can i try it out
yes
yes you can try it out for 30 days money
back
guarantee that's right try it out you
got nothing to lose
oh oh god he's gonna kill his guy he's
bloodthirsty
oh god camera like the monitor
i saw a vent closed when somebody go in
it okay it wasn't
toast so the imposter can vent okay good
to know
so we left rey with michael in the top
right
michael did you kill ray she was on to
you
he's laughing guys
i don't think it's michael he's laughing
way too hard
actually i'm actually not convinced
surprisingly enough yeah
but wait who's the uh do we know who the
other one is i thought it was rey
only because i saw her standing around
but but ray died
you're talking about yeah michael
convinced me to keep you alive
i love dogs me too oh is he doing it
waiting for toast boy all right toast
boy claire then
all right we're clear gang player gang
stick together
oh no [ __ ] i shouldn't have reported
what do you mean because me and ken and
lily were
glued and we were all clear we were
literally clear gang i've been sticking
with you this entire
time because i thought you were innocent
are you are you impressed
did you how dare you
we walked down together oh my god do not
do this to me lately please
if it was only lily felix and
whoever i mean that would mean it's lily
or felix right
no there's no way they're best buddies
wait i've been sticking with him yeah
wait i can walk
literally but
did you kill ken i would never i did not
i did not i believe that boy you guys
killing michael
or killing michael we get it wrong we
lose
yeah we're we're dead if we keep both
yeah we tried killing michael
i've been trying to kill michael this is
gonna get killed by him yeah we
gotta finish the job here lily did you
run that like honestly
you did didn't you you did run down
lily you literally saw me scan as well
there's like no reason no no no no no no
it doesn't show up i love the minion
skin by the way you could have sk
sure why would she kill him there it's
so so
scared i was so sure it wasn't lily
until she pulled that worst
move i've ever seen oh
you better not all right all right she's
not gonna kill me
being gaslight i don't think she'll kill
me
i think i don't think she'll do it for
the meme
oh my god i'm so confused
what is this game okay so i've been
sticking with lily this entire game
and then i don't know why she accused me
out of nowhere
so i thought for sure it was lily and
then lily died but the corpse i coaxed
that
cool you just have to take my word for
it i understand it's a tough plea
but that's the truth right lily made
this so hard for me
right i walked down all the way around i
checked electrical and when i walked in
felix was standing over her body you saw
me and reported it oh
that's pretty hard accusation yes i i
honestly hope it's toast at this point
just pitting everybody
against everybody else yeah i could
saw him in o2 there's no possible way it
could have been anyone else they
couldn't even have vented out unless
toast went all the way around the top
felix is that what happened did he see
you standing over the body
uh no so he's lying cor
comes stab lilly in electrical right in
front of me and he reports
never mind uh
this is so weird please you know felix
gets very vocal
when he's detective but when he's
imposter he gets a lot quieter
yeah because i'm so confused what
happened with lilly
like why did she accuse me she was
literally with me and now i look like
i'm the fool
in front of court she comes murdered in
plain sight literally
i don't know what do you think that's
what he's all right all right all right
keep me alive
corpse is the last imposter if you don't
trust that it's him
fair enough okay i'll vote for myself
why not
you know what oh thank you drag this out
a little longer thank you
thank you lily thank you all right
what the hell was that i'm just gonna
win
i'm so scared all right we're like glue
no not toast toast toast the [ __ ] is
toast doing
oh god i lost them okay they saw me do a
task there right
it's the most confused
i couldn't find you guys i was just
making sure everyone's alive you can
check admin
yeah where are you guys all together
crazy i'm no one died in that time where
you couldn't find anyone
i'm really shocked i'm just honestly
here for the drama at this point i just
want to see how this plays out i'm
voting you corpse i don't give a [ __ ]
holy you're killing you killed lily cold
blood
interesting how nobody's dead when you
were in a group with them
because one of them you're right that
does work two ways all right well
you guys saw me do a task right you paid
attention to the bar right
i did not i saw toast do tasks i think
yeah uh all right well follow me
if you don't want to believe it i don't
know what to tell you
wait corpse dead ass is it you
it's not me it's
felix felix triangle of trust is it you
uh i will not speak of the triangles oh
please pump felix
please toast i wish i listen
if i lose this i'm just shocked that my
friends would lie to me like that
oh my god dude
this is [ __ ] we're just dragging
this out we got dead people waiting
let's
let's go watch me do a task all right
watch me do a test i can do it pass
this game
oh my god he didn't kill anyone
unbelievable well he has to kill me
oh [ __ ] uh he has to kill jack he's
going to kill jack now
he's going to kill jack and brilliant on
me jack run
run jack he's gonna kill him
uh yeah it's toast oh
[Laughter]
why did you leave you know someone was
gonna die if you left
i thought it was i thought it was toast
because it went off
right when he walked in that direction
and i was like what the [ __ ]
jack you knew he was gonna kill you it
was three of us he obviously couldn't
kill me
why did you die
no [ __ ] up i'm leaving dude
we were the only thing next to each
i mean i never had hard evidence of
anything
and it's the lilly story and electric
kill that made very little sense
yeah it really was lilly's story right
holy [ __ ] corbs is just an incredible
liar
i wouldn't mind playing as imposter now
because that was stressed i never been
so stressed as a crew mate
chad says lily wants ping no no no no no
no no no it's fine no
it's fine it's fine no i'm not oh my god
he has a fedora now the fedora suits
your name doesn't matter
hey look at that guys look what i am
oh god no
a light kill it would seem well it's not
cor well it's not
i'm actually kind of glad course is dead
i'm not gonna lie this makes it so much
easier
i got a task on the north but then i saw
i was alone so i got scared so i ran
down and then i
saw a corpse body dead uh like down to
the right
before medvedev interesting information
here so corpse lily and i were the only
three that went to the top
right because i wanted to bang out the
telescope when the lights went off
stormed left i still want to do the
telescope and i don't know where
anyone this possible only corpse but i
immediately went to the electrical room
yeah i did see lily there yeah i i
didn't see so lily's saying that she was
at the scene of the crime so where did
you go after you killed that corpse
that's it that's all i have all right so
i just want to make sure this adds up so
you
walk from the medical area to the
election
that's like really fast walking to be
honest because no i didn't go into the
mid area
no but even if you i barely got to move
anything at all
i'm super cessing you lately but i won't
move for you don't worry
okay i i have a key piece of information
so
one person went to the ship task and
there was only one person and the bar
went up so we know we can completely
trust that one person
it's me wow
um good enough for me super size i'm
watching you dark lily if you keep me
alive i can solve this mystery not me
though
i trust you toast just don't kill me
okay
i'm not then
i knew it was michael god damn it
he was so quiet dude i hate the vision
thing because of that because i can't
run away
oh it's not lily oh wait oh lily's not
pink oh my
gosh but i wasn't i need to help you
that's definitely new he just got me
killed to help lily
[Music]
michael are you gonna stand up for your
girlfriend quiet i'm like all right
[Music]
hey
hmm